from a bike ride with an alien to a
father-son lightsaber battle these
sci-fi scenes are Fantastical
Unforgettable and infinitely
re-watchable
the Death Star attack and Trench Run in
Star Wars A New Hope is one of the most
iconic sequences in the history of film
it's arguably the most famous sequence
in the entire Star Wars saga and it sets
the tone at the very beginning for how a
Star Wars space battle should look and
feel George Lucas and his team famously
Drew inspiration from dogfights in World
War II dramas and that influence is
palpable the whole battle takes place in
the open vacuum of space yet every
shutdown fighter and close engagement is
packed with tight frenetic energy
narratively this scene is just as iconic
from Luke turning off his targeting
computer for the impossible shot to Han
flying in at the last second to save his
friend's skin is full of tropes in the
best way John Williams triumphant score
booms in the background and the Death
Star does the same
[Music]
if you're a fan of sci-fi movies Roy
Batty's words in the rain are probably
very familiar to you I'm
seeing things you people wouldn't
believe spoken by Rutger Howard's
character at the end of Ridley Scott's
magnum opus Blade Runner this brief
speech might be the most quoted and
lauded monologue in the history of the
genre in just 42 words batty sums up so
much of the film's complexity Rick
Deckard has spent the entire film
hunting batty and his fellow Rogue
replicant Androids as a Blade Runner
that's his job but says he and the
viewer become more confused as to the
nature of his own humanity and does the
clear Injustice of replicant life
becomes clearer the story blurs in the
end batty saves Rick's life and he
chooses to spend his final moments
sharing some of his unique experiences
there's an intangible blend of Joy
sorrow and wishfulness that Howard
delivers poetically conveying what
philosophical Exposition couldn't
possibly manage to do any life is a
beautiful thing and any death is a
tragic one like
tears
in rain
the ending of Alex Garland's critically
acclaimed 2018 film Annihilation is one
of the most beautiful baffling unnerving
and memorable moments in recent Sci-Fi
history biologist Lena spends a film
journeying through a patch of wilderness
surrounded by a strange energy field
known as the Shimmer which has been
slowly emanating outward from a crashed
meteor within the genes of all life have
been scrambled and gorgeous and hideous
ways but that's nothing compared to what
Lena finds in the Lighthouse at the
center of the Shimmer Lena discovers her
lost squad leader Dr Ventress and the
tower who gives her a dark and cryptic
warning her bodies and her Minds will be
fragmented into their smallest Parts
until
not one part remain
Ventress evaporates and becomes light
the light becomes a body and the body
becomes leaner Under The Haunting
strangeness of Ben Salisbury and Jeff
Barrow's musical score Lena under alien
double engage in a dance-like duel with
violent ends it's Cosmic horror at its
truest and most powerful a vision of
alien life so different from ours that
it defies explanation many have tried to
explain the ending of annihilation but
the mystery is why it's so flawless
Interstellar isn't necessarily the most
original sci-fi film of the 21st century
but that hasn't stopped it from becoming
one of the most beloved in style and
tone the film is very similar to the
rest of Christopher Nolan's filmography
thematically it reads like a modern
version of 2001 A Space Odyssey a movie
that's fascinated with both the
theoretical science and strangeness of
space however Interstellar shines
brightest in its most human moments and
if you've seen the movie one scene in
particular it's probably leaping to mind
right now in an effort to find New
Horizons for Humanity Joseph Cooper and
the rest of the endurance team a task
was visiting several different planets
in orbits around the black hole
Gargantua their first stop is an
hour-long visit to an aquatic world that
unfortunately brings nothing in the way
of scientific Revelation due to
miscalculations of the black hole's time
dilation and an unforeseen tragedy on
the planet's surface Cooper and Dr
Amelia brand returned to the endurance
to find out 23 years have passed this
moment is designed to wreck you before
the mission even really gets started the
crews broken as Cooper watches two
decades of backlogged video messages
from its now grown children he
completely breaks down the music from
Hans Zimmer a composer famous for
sweeping anthems and soaring strings is
quiet here as if it too has been hushed
by the terrifying vastness and power of
space
it's not every year that we get a new
film worthy of the Sci-Fi Cinema
Pantheon but 2022 brought an instant
classic with everything everywhere all
at once the hilarious emotional and
infinitely creative family drama from
directors Daniel Kwan and Daniel
scheinert is a rare film that occupies
the space all its own even in the modern
crowd of Multiverse movies everything
everywhere all at once stands out a
movie is a Non-Stop roller coaster of
bizarre alternate realities and exciting
martial arts action all anchored by a
powerful story about the things we give
up for the people we love in the third
act though things really kick into high
gear protagonist Evelyn fully locks into
the Mozzy verse she's been accessing and
starts racing through it at a fever
pitch leading to a stunning Montage of
different realities flashing by her in
an instant it's a perfect encapsulation
of the film's Unique Style and a moment
that leaves a lasting impression
everything from animated universes to
Celestial Landscapes and snowy city
streets flash by while the camera stays
rooted firmly on Evelyn's face we see
the infinite possibilities of her life
and we feel the weight of the decisions
she's made though the Montage itself
only lasts a moment and leads to an
equally frenetic final act with plenty
of other wild scenes everything
everywhere all at once beautifully
balances chaos with grounded emotion and
it all comes together flawlessly at the
end
in 2010 hearts of the star-making
success of the Dark Knight Christopher
Nolan dropped an original sci-fi
Masterpiece that took the World by storm
Inception was a success on many levels
achieving High marks from critics and
raking in cash at the box office with a
star-studded cast it also introduced a
sound effect that has haunted
Blockbuster trailers ever since because
the dream sharing technology at the
center of inception is so high concept
it's easy to forget that the film is
still at its heart a heist movie but
when you hit the climax that becomes
pretty clear after diving down into the
Forbidden third level of Target Robert
Fisher's dream world the crew prepares
for extraction to get out they trigger
kicks weightless moments are weak
dreamers in all three active dream
levels at once this causes time gravity
and the Very fabric of reality to
unravel in different ways across the
different layers resulting in one of the
most intense unique and impressively
shot Sci-Fi Action sequences ever
calling 2001 A Space Odyssey influential
would be a dramatic understatement
Stanley Kubrick and Arthur C Clarke's
1968 sci-fi epic basically defined an
entire era for the genre and it's still
one of the most thought about movies
today in truth any number of scenes
could be plugged from the film for this
list we could talk about the infamous
star child ending or the bizarre
monolith sequences but instead let's
talk about the scene that everybody
loves to quote open the pod bay doors
hell the iconic line itself is
recognizable to many people who have
never even seen the movie It's the
moment that our protagonist astronaut
Dave Bowman realizes that his ship's AI
isn't just Sinister but way way ahead of
him I know that you and Frank were
planning to disconnect me
and I'm afraid that's something I cannot
allow to happen 2001 is more about tone
and atmosphere than it is about a
straightforward story and this scene is
the ultimate example of that the
unsettling sound of Howe's mechanical
voice intercourt with shots of the empty
ship in the Dark Void of space creates a
sense of instant Unstoppable dread
although you took very thorough
precautions in the pond against my
hearing you
I could see your lips move Dave's own
shots are claustrophobic and we see the
fear play out on his face as Hal shows
his hand in an age when AI technology is
becoming a bigger part of our lives
every day this scene is even more
foreboding than it was in 1968.
many of Steven Spielberg's most famous
films fall into the Sci-Fi genre
including 1977's Close Encounters of the
Third Kind Spielberg's first movie after
breaking out as a blockbuster director
with jaws in 1975. Close Encounters is a
movie all about aliens but it plays out
more like a mystery than a
straightforward drama or action movie in
fact there's very little action to speak
of at all even when Humanity finally
makes contact with the extraterrestrials
the ending of Close Encounters is as
beautiful as it is mystifying the aliens
finally touched dome in Wyoming where
the U.S military has laid out a welcome
party to communicate the humans use a
combination of light patterns on a giant
screen and musical notes inspired by the
aliens own strange sounds in this way
the two species are able to communicate
though is still a bit unclear what that
conversation entails but then again
that's kind of the point the audio
visual communication with the aliens is
tonally perfect maintaining the alluring
Mystique of the rest of the film while
also offering a satisfying resolution we
don't get concrete answers about what
the aliens of done or what they want but
we do get a powerful resonant moment of
connection between two corners of the
universe even decades later the scene is
absolutely breathtaking
a lot of the best moments in sci-fi
movie history are scenes that challenge
viewers intellectually giving form to
impossible things or exploring
mind-blowing ideas some though are great
simply because it's fun to see big beefy
dudes fight aliens with knives in the
jungle Predator may not be the most
thought-provoking science fiction movie
but it's a certified classic the first
action movie from director John mcternan
who later conquered the genre with the
Die Hard franchise follows a squad of
muscle-bound military Commandos on a
routine Mission into a South American
jungle things go awry when they start to
be hunted by an invisible
extraterrestrial foe the Predator Itself
by the time and Final Act rolls around
it's just Dutch and the predator
slathered in mud to avoid the aliens
thermal vision Dutch lays traps
ambushing his enemy in the same way it's
been taking out his comrades sparks fly
in the jungle lights up with fire and
explosions as the two Titans go at it we
even get a few Choice one liners along
the way to keep things light
I
sometimes a great scene doesn't need to
tap into the deepest recesses of your
mind sometimes it just needs to be
fleshy and fun and the ending of
Predator is exactly that
there are lots of things to love about
the Wachowski sisters breakout sci-fi
Masterpiece from the stunning visual
style and rip roaring action to the
heady AI storyline and in truth many
different moments could justify spots on
this list the red pill blue pill scene
for instance or the slo-mo lobby
shootout that kicks off the Final Act
but one moment Stands Tall Above the
Rest when Neo finally unlocks his true
potential
what are you trying to tell me
that I can dodge bullets after seemingly
being killed by agent Smith and his
compatriots it looks like Neo might not
be the one after all but a real world
kiss from Trinity gives him a second win
and when he stands up he's a very
different man as foretold by Morpheus
Neo bloxy agents bullets had their
nothing and when Smith comes in for a
closer attack he remains equally
Untouchable suddenly the most dangerous
forces in The Matrix are reduced to
frightened children and Neo finishes
Smith off with an explosive display of
his reality altering power this moment
has only made better by the final shot
of the film which sees Neo take flight
for the first time
Trump might not have been a huge success
in 1982. but it's become a cult classic
since and this historical impact can't
be understated according to the guardian
Trump was one of the first feature films
to use CGI in a major way which fit
perfectly with its experimental cyber
world setting the most famous action set
piece from the film today is probably
the light cycle battle sequence a combat
racing scene that was incredibly
ambitious for its time decades ago the
original Tron might have made it on this
list with its life cycles sadly the
scene hasn't aged especially well but
fans got a renovated version in 2010's
Tron legacy director of the original
film and the producer on the sequel
Stephen lisberger told den of geek that
the light cycles and Trump Legacy looked
a lot more like what they were going for
in the early 80s the same could be said
of the entire life cycle battle too now
this I can do in Tron legacy the combat
race is nearly operatic anchored and
elevated by Daft Punk Stella soundtrack
every movement is timed to the music
creating a scene that's more like a
cyberspace music video and a typical
action set piece while it may not be the
most important moment in the movie's
overall narrative the light cycle battle
is everything it needs to be it's great
to see a classic scene Revitalize so
well and the score is just the icing on
the cake now that's what I'm talking
about
George Miller's 2015 film Mad Max Fury
Road isn't just a sequel to his classic
Trilogy from decades earlier it's a
partial reboot and quasi-reimagining
that incorporates elements from every
prior film picking a single moment from
Fury Road to include is Turf because the
film is basically one long chase scene
however there probably isn't a more
memorable sequence than the sandstorm
battle than the First Act from the
pull-out shot that shows a gargantuan
size of the storm to the final shot of
nux's flare burning out into the
darkness the whole sequence is
breathtaking it's the perfect way to
convey the natural brutality of this
world and the fragility of human life
within it
the movie fans of a certain age ET is a
quintessential alien movie it's
Untouchable in its Simplicity the story
of a young boy who finds for friends and
fights to protect a gentle
extraterrestrial left behind by his
people with Steven Spielberg's
impeccable Direction and John Williams
for infant score the film takes his
basic pitch and makes it a deeply
emotional journey and of course it also
features perhaps the most famous shot in
80s film you already know the one with
E.T bundled in a blanket on the front of
his bike Elia goes for an evening ride
and thanks to the alien Supernatural
Powers they're able to take flight the
shot of the bike Crossing in front of
the Moon might as well be the logo for
Hollywood Blockbusters even decades
after it first dazzled audiences
Williams music soars in the background
just as E.T and Elliot fly before our
eyes it's the kind of scene that's made
Spielberg one of the most lauded
directors of all time and it just might
be his finest moment
Really Scott Saiyan is one of the most
beloved and influential films in the
entire sci-fi genre both threats
massively implemented horror elements
and this dense environmental World
building most of the action takes place
on the Nostromo a mining ship on his way
back to Earth that's infiltrated by a
deadly alien Predator called a xenomorph
the whole reason that the xenomorph gets
on board at all though is that the ship
receives a signal from a nearby Moon
myelen utsani company policy demands
that the crew investigate leading to A
gorgeously unsettling Expedition onto an
alien spacecraft from the Stark
Landscapes of the Moon itself to H.R
giga's designs for the alien ship this
whole sequence oozes atmosphere in dread
it captures the otherworldly nature of
what's about to happen flawlessly and
things only get more unsettling when the
first Facehugger appears there are
plenty of other horrifying moments in
Alien but the whole tone is set during
this first Contact sequence without
directly explaining anything this film
effortlessly conveys a terrifying
strangeness of the universe which is the
whole point after all in space no one
can use scream
the Star Wars franchise is so important
to the Sci-Fi genre at large that it
earns two entries on this list and there
should be no doubt that The Empire
Strikes Back is deserving from the snowy
battle on Hearth in the first stack to
Yoda's Jedi teachings on Dagobah the
film is loaded with memorable moments
but the sequence we've chosen is
particularly significant Star Wars is
nothing if not loyal to narrative
traditions and a showdown between Luke
Skywalker and Darth Vader on Cloud City
that's about his hero's journey as it
gets it's easily the best saber fight in
the original Star Wars Trilogy and it
ends with one of Cinema's most memorable
plot twists as Vader holds out his hand
to his son promising wealth and power if
they join forces we see in Luke's eye is
a combination of Terror and hate join me
and together we can rule the galaxy is
Father and Son and yeah to Luke Dodges
the dark side instead letting himself
fall rather than to join his father it's
a moment that's been done a hundred
times in a hundred stories but it's
never been more iconic than in Star Wars
foreign